so room reinvented dcom lets you
transform your space using AI you can do
rustic Art Deco coal contemporary I took
this empty standard New York or La
apartment empty room and then they allow
you to upload it and then you can pick a
type of style you want to decorate the
room in this is just looking at this
room in like a Scandinavian style here I
did this Bohemian style this is the step
before you're starting to put the
furniture in it's like how do I want
this room to look I picked these two
dramatically different ones you know
obviously Bohemian and Scandinavian or
yes one is sparse and one is colorful
playful you could do iasa in here or
something and it' be fine it looks like
you could do some kind of a ceremony
sitting on the floor there and then the
other one Scandinavian looks like you
could play Scrabble sitting on the floor
yeah both would be drinking tea